in a rare even historic move amnesty
international denounced russia's
unlawful use of force as a violations of
the united nations charter and an act of
aggression a crime under international
law
this is a move we very rarely make the
evidence we have gathered since the
russian invasion of ukraine began in
late february 2022 it implicates russian
military forces in serious violations
of international law including
extrajudicial killings
disproportionate indiscriminate attacks
against civilians
including in densely populated area
deployment of cluster munition that
being so indiscriminate are banned under
international law abuses against
civilians living under siege and failure
to protect and secure humanitarian
corridors
in other words we know that the crimes
committed against people living around
kiev which we are reporting on today are
not merely anecdotal
incidental or collateral
we know they are part of a pattern that
has characterized
russia's conduct of the hostilities from
the outset
a repeated pattern
large in scale and devastating in impact